Sadie Pfeiffer was nine years old when
this photo was taken
operating heavy machinery that's nearly
twice her height in a cotton mill in
Lancaster South Carolina in 1908 she was
just one of many children working in
Mills fields factories and mines and
although these kids were spread across
the United States working in separate
industries they all had one thing in
common they all met Lewis Hine at the
turn of the 20th century the United
States knew it had a child labor problem
the 1900 federal census revealed that
1.75 million children under the age of
16 more than one in five were working at
this time the Industrial Revolution had
mechanized American and European
manufacturing and a cheap labor force
was needed to complete repetitive tasks
for hours on end children from poor
families were targeted for these jobs
because they would work for next to
nothing and were less likely to strike
than adults state legislators and the
American public knew this was happening
on a mass scale but didn't act until
they saw what it actually looked like
starting in 1908 the newly formed
national child labor committee hired a
photographer to investigate and report
on the industries employing children
that photographer was Louis Wix Hine
educator sociologist and member of the
progressive movement a period in the
United States that saw a wave of
political activism and social reform
Hine emphasized the potential power of
photography as a tool for social reform
in a speech he gave in 1909 called
social photography how the camera may
help
he said the dictum then of the social
worker is let there be light and in this
campaign for light we have the light
writer the photograph he traveled
extensively gathering information
interviews and images of working
children across the country
he visited coal mines in Pennsylvania
where adolescent Breaker boys worked
underground for hours separating
impurities from coal sardine cutters in
Maine moister suckers in Louisiana some
as young as four years old tobacco
pickers in Kentucky
cranberry pickers in Massachusetts beet
farms in Colorado and young messengers
and newsboys in cities all over the
country many of the photos captured
adults nearby supervising the children
as they worked when Hine wasn't allowed
access to the mills and factories he
waited outside and documented the
comings and goings of its workers whose
shifts often lasted late into the night
laborers would pose for portraits and
tell high and a bit about themselves
their wages and their work conditions
sometimes they showed their horrific
injuries and described what happened
like this boy from Bessemer City North
Carolina whose hand got crushed in the
gears of a cotton spinner we know that
because each photo numbering over 5000
includes a detailed caption written by
high
Hynde coined the term photo stories to
describe this marriage of images and
text and it's a big part of how the
photos humanized the lives of child
laborers to an indifferent public but
it's also his photographic technique
that makes them feel so personal let's
use the photos of cotton mill workers
like Sadie as an example first many of
these photos are framed the exact same
way just substituting a different worker
pine was trying to show that each
child's experience was part of a
widespread problem and the repetition in
the images signals that you can really
see how intentional the framing is when
you look at how the image of Sadie
appeared when it was first published in
a progressive magazine in 1909 its
opposite a nearly identical photo of a
different worker set so that the
symmetry of the two images makes the
machinery seem to go on and on the
left-hand caption that says spinner a
type of many in the mill Hines
photographs are also shot with a very
shallow depth-of-field
which basically means a narrow part of
the photo is in focus and the rest is
blurred out a photo with a deep depth of
field would look like this one by Jacob
Riis who was photographing New York City
slums around the same time
notice how the playground in the
background is in focus just like the
kids in the foreground now look at Hines
portraits
in this one the factory this boy works
at looms behind him but it's almost
totally blurred out this was a recurring
visual theme to include the machinery or
the workplace in the frame but obscure
it favoring the worker instead this
narrow point of focus combined with
shooting from a lower angle the eye
level of these children is why these
images are so effective at humanizing
their subjects photos like the ones from
the South Carolina cotton mills changed
the public perception of child labor in
the United States ultimately pressuring
state legislators to introduce laws
regulating work for those under the age
of 18 and sending kids back to school
Lewis Hine went on to photograph the
construction of the Empire State
Building in New York City using the same
dignifying techniques he photographed
child laborers with considering the
perspective of his subjects with a
narrow focus emphasizing the worker not
the machinery Hine was one of the first
to use a camera as a tool for social
documentary to shine a light on the
mostly unseen he understood early on the
power images have to tell stories as he
said in that 1909 speech take the
photograph of a tiny spinner and a
Carolina cotton mill with a picture thus
sympathetically interpreted what a lever
we have for the social uplift
[Music]
hey everyone that was dr. season one I'm
gonna take a break from it and work on
some other stuff like history club with
Phil if there are photos that you think
would make good stories for the next
season make sure to leave a comment
below in the meantime if you're looking
for more great videos on photography and
history check out the documentary the
man who shot Tutankhamun available on
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers you can get
unlimited access
starting at $2.99 a month and because
you're a Vox fan the first 31 days are
free if you sign up at curiosity string
comm slash Vox and use the promo code vo
X curiosity stream doesn't impact our
editorial but their support makes videos
like this one possible so go check them
out